on va parler aujourd'hui de deux choses
qui vous semblent complètement ou
poser complètement
voir on va parler de critiquer et de
cyclones on va nommer notre petit
criquet gérard parce que ça va vous
faire un petit peu sourire mais si c'est
non mon frère et vous verrez l'histoire
de la vie de gérard
l'effet papillon retenait bien ça on va
comprendre quel est le lien entre ces
deux choses qui n'ont rien à voir
alors on va avoir une carte centrale et
je vais sortir de la carte de temps en
temps pour vous parler un peu de science
have avoir rappelé quelques cours de
biologie
vous avez en ligne rouge les limites de
la vie du cric et donc il va vivre dans
la zone en rouge le criquet pèlerin il y
en a plusieurs et vous avez en bleu les
endroits où il ya des cyclones qui se
produisent dans cette partie du globe
donc sur la péninsule arabique et sur la
corne africaine
on va se placer en 2019 2020 puisqu'il
ya eu une catastrophe qui a coûté 300
millions de dollars aux africains
c'est l'invasion des criquets pèlerins
sur la corne africaine sur la péninsule
arabique et même jusqu en afghanistan et
au pakistan
à première vue en fait il n'y a pas trop
de liens entre ces trois couleurs la bla
zone verte où il ya eu des dégâts n'a
pas trop de liens que les cyclones mais
se situe bien sûr dans la zone rouge le
lieu de vie des criquets pèlerins
allez on prend un peu d'auteurs on sort
de la carte maintenant on va faire de la
biologie ça va vous rappeler des
souvenirs et je commence par des figures
que vous détestez tous le cycle de la
vie de gérard alors
on va prendre un oeuf un oeuf de
criquets pèlerins qui se développe dans
le sol il va y avoir quatre ou cinq
stades larvaires suivant les conditions
météorologiques et puis s'ils ont à
manger voilà un stade jeunes et les uns
sans délai et puis gérard se trouve une
femme il fait d eux et puis ça
recommence
le cycle dure de assume 2 à 6 mois
suivant les conditions météorologiques
température humidité sont extraits moins
important pour les oeufs pour la survie
des oeufs s'il fait trop chaud trop
froid les hommes heures s'il n'y a pas
d'eau il ne se développe pas
température humidité sont aussi très
importants pour les stades larvaires
puisqu'il compte on considère aussi qui
permet de faire pousser les plantes pour
qu'ils puissent se nourrir s'il n'y a
pas d'eau l'époque mon goût spar et y
meurent de faim
prédation cannibalisme et parasites ce
sont des choses supplémentaires que j'ai
rajouté pour être précis parce que je
suis un scientifique mais ça ne sert à
rien dans cette présentation
gérard va manger 2 g de végétaux par
jour c'est l'équivalent de son poids ça
veut dire pour un homme s'il mangeait 75
kg de nourriture par jour c'est très
conséquents pour une si petite bête
à un moment gérard il a et des
conditions météorologiques qui lui sont
très favorables à sa croissance et aussi
à la croissance des plantes qui
l'entourent
gérard qui est jaune dans une forme
solitaire va devenir noir dans une forme
grégaire rigueur ça veut dire en groupe
et avec une forte une forme très anciens
intermédiaires lorsque les conditions
météorologiques sont favorables on
arrive à des situations comme ça
c'est à dire une catastrophe agricole la
population d'un cric et peut se
multiplier parfum en trois mois
lorsqu'on passe dans la forme grégaire
une forme extrêmement grave c'est à dire
que gérard peut avoir des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants en juste trois mois
j'imagine même pas les couches alors
jusqu'à 80 millions d'individus 80 80
millions d'individus par kilomètre carré
est plus important que la population
française par kilomètre carré et ça
consomme jusqu'à 35 mille
repas on va dire d'africains par jour
c'est extrêmement conséquent un
kilomètre carré 35000 personnes en moins
à nourrir
on reprend la carte alors maintenant
j'ai rajouté les zones
de grégarisation des criquets pèlerins
ce sont les zones où potentiellement il
ya suffisamment d'eau suffisant eu des
temps part a de bonne température et
suffisamment de végétaux à manger pour
que les les criques et passe en forme
grégaire c'est un peu comme l'évolution
des pokémon mais en version grave donc
là je vous avais les seins de 2019 2020
germi envers les zones et on remarque en
fait y'a toujours pas de lien vous savez
toujours pas où est ce que je veux en
venir
et je retrace la vie de gérard comment
il sait dépasser il n'a pas pris l'avion
il a volé il peut parcourir jusqu'à
150 km par jour
c'est très important par rapport à sa
taille imaginez-vous
donc gérard il est apparu fin 2018 au
yémen il ya eu une forme de
grégarisation puisqu'il y avait
suffisamment d'eau suffisamment de
végétaux à manger et puis il a fait ces
milliers de petits enfants début 2019 il
a décidé de partir avec sa famille
puisqu'il n'avait plus rien à manger et
donc avec suivant lol la direction des
vents il s'est déplacé il a traversé les
mers et puis il est arrivé jusqu'en
afghanistan pakistan début 2019
d'après la fao toujours il a traversé de
nouveau des mères en juin 2019 pour se
rendre sur la corne africaine et puis il
s'est pendu dans tous les pays autour de
la corne africaine au kenya ça faisait
75 ans qu'on n'avait pas vu une
catastrophe agricole pareil et c'était
la première fois depuis 1944 que ces
criquets et une à tignes et le congo
malgré l'apparition des pesticides bon
il ya eu d'autres phénomènes comme le co
vide qui n'ont pas fait qu'on a lancé
alerte suffisamment tôt alors ce n'est
pas le cas vite je raconte des bêtises
mais il ya eu d'autres problèmes
géopolitiques qui ont fait qu'on a pas
lancé l'alertent suffisamment tôt
janvier 2020 gérard arrivent au kenya je
sors de la carte maintenant on va parler
des cyclones ça n'a rien à voir avec les
criquets mais vous allez comprendre
pourquoi je vais vous parler ce cyclone
d'un cyclone c'est une dépression
caractérisée par un oeil centrale il y
en a eu cinq qui ont touché l'arabie la
fin la péninsule arabique sa gare mais
que nul du ban ki ka et paone entre mai
2019 et descendre mais 2018 et décembre
ça fait de belles images des cyclones
tropicaux entouré de désert c'est pas
très courant et ils ont été plus
nombreux que d'habitude et là c'est la
figure la plus importante les premiers
qui m'écoute pas il va rien comprendre
il faut absolument m'écouter le 13 mai
2018 une image satellite
d'un désert à oman avant le cyclone
méconnu et après le 29 mai 2018 le même
désert avec des lacs les cyclones ont
apporté de l'eau au niveau de l'arabie
saoudite et c'est cette eau là qui a
permis au jeu de se développer aux
larves de se développer ensuite les
végétaux ont poussé et les criques et
avait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
gregarii zay
et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu à un moment
dans le ligne dans le yémen je dis des
bêtises depuis le début dans le yémen
une grégarisation qui s'est ensuite
étendu j'ai rajouté les trajets des cinq
cyclones en bleu sur cette carte avec
les noms au dessus
vous allez me dire mais il ya quand même
des trous mais il ya des mois où il n'ya
pas de cyclos n'y a pas d'eau c'est un
désert pourquoi ça a quand même
favoriser l'apparition des criquets
cette fois ci on va parler de
circulation atmosphérique vous connecter
tous un dipôle là je vais parler du
dipôle de l'océan indien mais vous
connaissez tous un dipôle c'est el nino
et niña
c'est le plus célèbre c'est forcément
celui qui nous impacte mais là je vais
vous parler des dipôles dans l'océan
indien
il peut y avoir une différence de
température entre je veux pas rentrer
dans les détails en sinon on pourrait
passer des heures mais on a une
différence de température entre des eaux
chaudes et des eaux froides et cela va
favoriser en fait les précipitations sur
la corne africaine qui dit
précipitations dit plus de pluie 10 des
criques et qu'ils ont plus d'eau et donc
des végétaux qui pousse plus de
nourriture est une forme de
grégarisation je rajoute sur mon
graphique le dipôle de l'océan indien et
tout au long de l'année en fait il y a
eu de l'apport d'humidité et cette
humilité a permis la grégarisation des
criquets et à partir de là c'est l'effet
papillon comme je vous ai au début un
cyclone qui apporte de l'eau dans le
désert du yémen provoque une catastrophe
agricole à 2000 kilomètres de là
merci la technologie avant que vous me
posez la question aux peaux qui arrive
dans pas très longtemps
le changement climatique parce qu'il
faut toujours raconté le changement
climatique et les catastrophes le
changement climatique est ce qu'ils
impactent ce processus là
4.10 le dipôle les cyclones la
température et la sécheresse on commence
par lesdits polar c'est une figure très
compliqué mais on va pas tout détailler
sinon on va dépasser le temps en bleu
vous avez les années où il ya un dipôle
faible envers vous avez les années où il
y un dipôle modéré et en rouge vous avez
les 10 pôles extrêmes
ici de ce côté là je ne sais pas de quel
côté vous être mais de ce côté là il ya
le contrôle la période du siècle passé
et là il ya le changement climatique
vous remarquez qu'avec la figure du
changement climatique les points rouges
y en a beaucoup plus ça veut dire que
les 10 pôles vont être plus violent donc
le dit paul va apporter va être plus
fréquents plus violents et va donc
apporter plus d'eau sur la péninsule
arabique et donc les criques et vont
pouvoir passer en forme grégaire donc
les diplômes les diplômes les 10 pôles
sont positifs pour les criquets enfin
pas pour nous pour les criquets nous
après on a moins de nourriture les
cyclones ont maintenant vous avez ici le
tracé ce graphique va vous vous montre
le nombre de cyclones qu'il ya sur la
péninsule arabique depuis 1950 il n'y a
pas de tendance à la hausse on est
plutôt sur des cycles et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que dit leur dernier rapport du
giec j'espère que vous l'avez tous lui
pas de tendance sur le nombre total
d'événements cyclonique donc on est
plutôt sur quelque chose de stable
légèrement cyclique par contre on a une
augmentation des événements de type
extrême et un chiffre à retenir c'est
chaque degré de gagner dans l'atmosphère
ces 7 % de plus d'humidité dans
l'atmosphère et non plus de pluie
donc plus depuis plus de cliquer par
contre les tendances sont compliquées au
niveau des descentes d'échelle au niveau
des bassins et donc il ya encore des
choses à approfondir dans ses recherches
là donc pour les cyclones plus depuis
c'est positif pour les criques et la
température maintenant vous avez en
abscisse la température en ordonner le
temps d'un cul parce d'incubation des
oeufs
plus il fait chaud plus les eaux le
temps d'incubation est plus court ça
veut dire que plus le cycle de
croissance du criquet et cours et dont
plus il fait chaud puis les criques et
se reproduisent rapidement la
température est donc positive également
pour la croissance des criquets et une
dernière image dont c'est une image de
l'ipc si c'est la traduction en anglais
du giec vous avez si la corne africaine
que vous vous distinguez et l'arabie
saoudite j'ai pris la figure officielle
qui n'est pas très clair frappe je leur
dise mais vous voyez que on est plutôt
dans des zones en bleu sur les bords de
mer là où les cyclones impact c'est à
dire que consécutive nadal c'est à dire
les jours consécutifs de sécheresse il y
en aura - les sécheresses seront plus
courtes il n'y a pas que des sécheresses
avec le changement climatique et aux
siens un bouleversement du climat en
général ont tué par des sécheresses qui
seront plus courtes n'ont plus depuis ça
veut dire que comme bon climatologues
qui se respectent actuellement je vous
dis encore une mauvaise nouvelle vers
une hausse du risque de ces problèmes
des criques et en afrique de l'ouest et
donc des problématiques géopolitiques et
agricoles et donc alimentaire
je vous remercie de votre attention